the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
okay so let's get started
a recap it should be all pleased you
have learned lot we cover the the
quantum solid state and the statistical
physics in its my lecture 11 and so what
we learn first the quantum is and the
solid state gives us the energy levels
and the energy state what is a quantum
state and statistics to give us at the
equilibrium each quantum state how many
particles photons electrons photons and
going back to counting the state
degeneracy we gathered n sub States side
the certain energy level per unit energy
interval or poor Union we vector how
many quantum states we have so with that
we can do the counting and this is a F
times D comes to the number of particles
near the energy per energy interval if
you integrate I should give you the
total number of a particles electrons
photons photons or if you multiply by
the energy of a particle that gives you
the energy if you multiplied by charge
give you the charge density if you
multiply by the momentum gives you
momentum right so with that you can
start doing the for example the energy
stored specific heat etc and then we
said at the end of last lecture we're
moving on to look at the transport and
the first idea which we look at is if I
want to find out how much energy is
going from point one to point two into a
different space and what I'm going to
find out is what's the transmittance so
if I have a partner or wave now I don't
know how the collab right it's part of
your wave duality and I see if I have
a carrier right you like to unfold on
photon launcher from point 1 and the
transmittance is how much how many of
them were reach point to write that so
give me the fraction right and then say
if I know the velocity then I know the
flux from point 1 to point 2 which is a
velocity in that direction transmittance
and if I want to find the energy flux
that's per se this is how much energy I
have starting from that point right so
this is where we're going in the common
chapter we're going to focus on using
the way picture to do is this
transmittance and then if I want to find
the left flux if you recall in Chapter 1
when we derived Fourier law we say the
from one to two and managed to do what
the difference gave me the left flux
right so a water were emphasized and so
far you know how to do the counting and
I'll focus in this chapter is talking
about the wave picture right we've been
using the way when Schrodinger equation
for atoms electrons and all wave picture
and if why we have to look at wave and
this is important if I deal with the
interface because I mentioned before
idea interface is zero thickness right
it's compared to wavelength if that is a
very small compared to witness then I
should use the way picture and so here
is a magnitude or a magnitude of this
wavelength right play body radiation
whence this displacement nor say
wavelengths times temperature is about
three thousand mikroc cowan so i room
temperature that's ten micron it's a
very large distance 10 micro you are
compared to a zero thickness interface
right so if I have a flat interface I
need to consider the wave optics so for
for yeah for you and for thermal
radiation and electrons here are two
different picture if I look at the
electron your mellow the Fermi level is
within the band and corresponding to
this formula what those are the electron
that moves near formula war are the
electron and most right and the
corresponding wavelength is waiting in
bands right this is zero this is PI over
a Brillouin zone so if it's half but
that's the wavelength is about to a okay
no see of the order of a few lattice
constant that's the electron wave
lengths in meadow there and if they look
at the semiconductors right if I say
this is a valence band and most of the
electron is at bottom of the valence
band so that's a lyric a equals zero and
those we've la electron Quahog will very
long wavelengths and in fact I say in
the last lecture we talked about that
the braga waveless so that's the thermo
if I
thermal energy KT of the C average
energy is KT of the electron kinetic
energy what's the corresponding
wavelength that's the Braga waveless
right so the last lecture we get the H
square and 2 pi M KBT so if I substitute
up my Lumbridge this is H is 6 point 6
10 to the minus 34 your second right
this is H and in the denominator I have
2 pi if I think about electron you like
from mass right line point 1 and 2 the
mass is 31 and KB is one point three
eight into the mass 23 and 300 Kalwa
square root you go to do that you get
this number
I get about 40 angstroms so it gives you
the sort of average wavelength of this
electrons with their energy KT near the
bottom of the conduction band
right so again this look 4040 I'm trans
seems awfully small but we said before
the sharp interface 0 thickness and in
fact you can deposit the layers almost a
comically flat right so again say if in
those cases you should consider the wave
refraction transmission just as the
optical waves and photons this is the
dispersion we learned before typical one
and of course I the zone boundary the
wavelengths is a 2 a right and agogo
suffer very long wavelength so this is
the sun waves if you have a solid they
lock it you hear it it's a very long
wavelengths at the zone center to the
hole just a 2 a in between the lattice
constant right and if you do you're like
a black body for full arm you do your
density of states you remember when we
do blackbody radiation with 2 energy
fold hand times in substage times the
Bose Einstein distribution that's how we
get blackbody radiation and you do the
same for foliar you say it's similar to
blackbody this spectrum except that
you're cut off you have a cutoff
wavelength because it's unlike
electromagnetic wave in free space that
one goes very small right so the lattice
constant to a lattice constant so
overall it's good if we started with the
thinking when I calculate the
transmission flex that I walk consider a
one single interface if I have one two
and I have those waves this could be
your like Tron wave could be Fulton
where and could be full-on when it comes
to the interface and they will be
reflected and they will also be could be
transmitting across the interface how
much how I can calculate how much is
reflective of how much transmitted right
so that's a my first order of business
and that will give me the transmission
from one side of interface to the other
side of interface right and of course I
could have layers or I could have many
layers right this is I'm considered
really a planar geometry make a 1d
problem simpler right so in this case
one and two and three or have multi
layers coding my user object coatings
right how I will calculate the
transmission and reflection and turns
out the waves are very similar whether
it's the electron wave or for long wave
or electromagnetic wave you will see the
behavior are very similar although I the
quantum level are really we know that
electron fall on photons are different
right but the general way be here in
terms of interference in terms
diffraction in terms of tunneling all
those exist for always
and there are different technology
developed based on this phenomenon so
let's look at star is a plan wave either
one interface right let's just consider
the simplest plan wave and their
reflection reflection other interface
you can see here I'm not even
distinguishing whether it's the electron
electron Marathi although my detailed
derivation will have to write style with
different wave equations right and in
this case I want to actually start with
the quantum wave or electron and that's
because that's the simplest electron if
you think about Schrodinger equation in
certain sense it's simple because it's
Keillor the wave function is scalar it's
a lot of vector when I go to acoustic
waves right the lattice vibration
they're three polarizes in two
transverse one non junior
electromagnetic wave it's a vector wave
the electric field is perpendicular to
the direction of propagation the two
polarization so I will start with the
simplest electron wave to the scalar
right and we have done the electron wave
Schrodinger equation before 2m deep sigh
I said let me think about the wine
electron 1 D DX square plus yo Marcy
this is the steady state part right
you must ye u is the potential is the
electron energy and of course there is a
time dependent part that so they
remember the time dependent part is just
a exponential minus I Omega T or this
Omega equals AE over H bar that's the
park relation right and for this way we
so over the before it's a simple second
order differential equation with
constant coefficient so we solve this
before and then let me write it down the
general wave form as if I combine the
time and the space dependent all
together that looks more like a wave
plan wave I Omega t minus K X plus B e
my mass I Omega T plus K X I have two
solutions right that's what we read in
down before now you can tell me the
first solution is a wave propagating
which direction positive X second wave
is the leg in the X direction right
that's either to counter propagating
waves and it's a superposition of two
waves now I'm going to look either if I
deposit a film with the interface right
so this interface I look at the 1d to
forget about that say Y Z direction and
so 1d interface this is a one side of
the film this is the other side of the
film
and this is a typically if you put a two
different semiconductor together right
and here is a conduction band EC one
here is a conduction band you see -
right so easy one you see - and at the
interface there's a discontinuity of the
energy of the electrons right and the
difference here is U or Delta the
different places have difference in both
and this is a typically called a hetero
Junction when I put a two different
conductors together semiconductor gether
at the interface there's a potential
barrier you're a trigger potential
barrier and the detail is more
complicated then I draw I draw a shop
watt and in fact that you like found
here is not stable it's going to fall
into here so it's not going to be a flat
as a flat as I'm drawing here here's a
very simple approximation okay and now I
have a electron wave comes in so I can
take a form of the incident wave and if
this is my extra ration at the interface
there will be refreshing the way will go
back right on the other side there could
be transmission the wave can go over the
barrier continue right so how reflashing
I have transmission I want to find how
much is reflected how much transmit it
okay so here you can use the plane wave
solution for medium one let me take this
yo as a reference this is zero here is
the electron here experience a
difference between zero and magnitude
you right so because of this Mike hey in
each
you see in region let's say here's my
zero origin of my coordinate and you can
always take your origin but typically
it's much easier if you said our raging
either interface at least like the first
interface if you have multi layers you
have to continue because there's
distance from your zero so you count
that distance right so if I put this Y
zero I have a incident wave plus I I
write this is the incident and has an
amplitude a and go into the right hand
side so exponential minus I Omega t
minus K 1 X because this is reaching 1
and this is region 2 right my K is
different because here okay Mike hey if
you look at this is 2m e my co / H
password you combine this together and
the reverse design MSE you now the you
Mossi okay so in this region yo equals 0
so whatever energy of the electron mass
potential 0 so that's the way for the
wave vector of K 1 right and they
reflect it here a poss-eye
this one this is a reflective way you
can see the reflective wave is going
backward right my coefficient is on B I
say I want to find out the reflashing a
and a B relation my transmitted wave in
region 2 so if I write down the
transmitted wave is a say exponential
again it's forward propagating into x2
the Russian positive acceleration right
so you say master I oh my god he must K
2 X naught K
wagons and this Kate who you can say is
a tool and II my co now H Square and the
k1 is just yo is zero so is 2m Yi is the
energy of the electron to M over 2m e
over H square right so this is the
difference of this waves here in region
1
they reflect incident reflected they
differ only by here is a plus here is
minus coefficients of the course are
different and transmitted a wave in
region 2 the coefficient is different we
vector is different to difference right
so I want to find out relation between 1
2
and my to find this relation I have to
use to continue the interface condition
right at the interface the wave function
is continuous the derivative of the wave
function is continuous so the wave
function so it's not just a one wave
function when it's the wave function is
all the waves order you add them all
together right you add a waves together
and so either the X square 0 what I have
is a poss-eye
I plus I are on the left hand side I
have two waves you see then reflected
right X go to 0 equals cosine T X is
equal to 0 what I get so the incident is
a X equal to 0 so k1 X that's 0 minus I
Omega T is shear the same Omega is the
energy of the alpha particle right e / H
is the same on both sides so when you go
the wave go from one media into the
other media the frequency doesn't change
okay and so what I have here is really a
plus B u course say no because the e
minus I Omega T mi ionia T and beside
here is the emails I Omega T that all
cancel right x equals zero so I have
that my second condition is a derivative
so it's a total derivative of all the
waves in that because the summations I
put each one so first take derivative
you have to be careful you first take
derivative you set equal to equal to
zero and this equals the river
here X go to 0 so if you take a
derivative here so you see with respect
to X so this is a I K right leg your leg
here so I have positive i ky a that's
the first term that's an incident
reflected is B and here is mass I trans
plastic so I have a sign change after I
take derivative right so a must be equal
I cry to time say so that's the
application of the two boundary
condition yes wrong
no the frequency doesn't change right
when you have light goes from one media
into another media the frequency does
not change the wavelength change okay so
this is a case my you remember HK gives
me a momentum P equals HK over I'll say
h-bar over lambda gave me the momentum
right so here is my two conditions and I
want to find the ratio because I want to
find transmissions say over a with
flashings B over a so a 20 question I
want to find ratio I can find those
ratios and the ratio I have is so based
on this I have a say over a is 2 k1 k1
plus k2 and the B over a is k1 man
schedule k-1 + k2 so those are my
solutions for the coefficient for the
transmitted wave and reflected wave
relative to the incident wave right but
what is this coefficient really doesn't
mean anything yet because we said before
the wave function is not a measurable
quantity right in quantum is the Prasad
x plus I complex conjugate that gives
the parkers right and the particle flux
in quantum
right the flux of the particle we give
this expression before is in the vector
form is the IH bar 2m and poss-eye
complex conjugate out for gradient of
the side and the side complex conjugate
times grading outside so that's the
particle flux and another way to write
this
if you real if you use a shorthand this
is real part for I h-bar and M beside
complex conjugate of for gradient
because this one is complex conjugate of
this one so the difference if the
overall is real part of this ok and now
I'm going to plug in because I want to
say what's my for example if I my
incident if a precise is my SI I write
you say precise is a exponential minus I
Omega t minus KX
okay so let's substitute the Y in so in
this case the incident flux is real
power of I h-bar
2m precise a exponential minus I Omega t
minus K 1 X that's the incident so the
derivative is a deep sigh I first take
complex conjugate and then I take the
derivative and complex honey I get this
one because of class because the I write
my side because I and the key one I'm
going to take a more uniform
I see it's a complex because the Omega
is a frequency we vector I'm going to
also say it could be real and imaginary
or complex number I treat it
in that case I have if I take a
derivative I should have passed that's I
and this is x mass complex conjugate k1
and exponential plus Omega t minus K 1 X
and right so oh I have all a I should
have a a here a complex conjugate okay
and minus I Omega T plus I Omega T
cancel time is not there right and I k
KY x plus i qi x oh here i should be
complex conjugate in general right
because I first take complex conjugate
of this function and so in general this
one mean na vi's arrow because this K 1
and plus K is complex conjugate they may
not cancel if it's a imagine number
right for my case here because in region
1 yo is 0 so this one is real doesn't
matter
and also either x equals 0 right this
also goes out so at the end is J watch
it at least I can say at the expert 0
you can say this is a H square 8 times
the 8 complex when I get I times I is a
negative 1 another Nate here right so
that's a positive so I really have this
I this I can so I have a a em H and K 1
so G 1 equals H M and K 1
a square okay so this is my particle
flux use it in the flux and similarly
the reflective flux is also if you
substitute the yen it's a cent is a HK 1
MB square right
but the transmitted flux I have to be
careful okay the reason I have to be
careful is you can say my solution if
energy is less than your k2 easy
measuring okay so in that case I have to
be really carrying the real part of K 2
complex conjugate because this is a
complex conjugate tool and the real part
of that that's where I have to be
careful okay
so based on this I would define the
reflectance and transmittance sometimes
use reflectivity sometimes I reuse the
reflectance and the difference is some
people most people don't distinguish it
reflectivity is more intrinsic so if you
have a most ideas case that's an
intrinsic surface property and
reflectance is extrinsic if your surface
become changed or raw for them there's a
different value so this is a more
rigorous way of calling it but you can
most of time people don't care so
reflect tivity for here my idea
is JR / ji and because k1 console in the
same media so reflected transmitted so
he really just have is a be square over
a square and
be square over a square if you see B
over a so I have K 1 minus K 2 and K 1
plus K 2 square so that's the
reflectance at the interface for a
particle wave due to quantum reflash
right and transmittance or
transmittivity and there's also
transmittance and in the transmittance
are use tau equals j t / ji and here
it's different because j transmitted is
a real part of okay two complex
conjugate / KY is real anyway and here i
have say square over a square and this
is a real power of k 2 complex conjugate
k 1 and say square over a square you can
say it is K 1 plus K 2 + 2 K 1 square
right
that's my transmittance okay now because
I carry this real part right
I should really look at the scenario
different scenario well energy is a
larger than u if energy is larger than
yo Kate who is come K 2 if you look at
the k2
is to MMIC oh that's real right the
energy of the electron is larger than
the barrier hi that's real okay
and in that is case rial so it's I can
forget about this so you can see this
becomes a for k1 times k2 divided by k1
plus k2 squared okay so in this case I
have a Tao is not zero but they say R is
not one right
I have quando reflection you might throw
a electron you even you're normally
single electron as a particle when it
comes to an interface it has a
reflection right even if the energy is
higher than the barrier height so now I
just say next time you through a walk
through a walk over the wall there's a
finite probability bounce back even you
through the higher than the wall it's
quantum Ward right okay and so that's
your first case and your second case is
a ye less than your right is less than Y
all if you look at the here york a tool
is imaginary right k2 is imaginary and
that the real part that's zero so if the
energy of the electron is less than the
barrier height yo your transmittance is
zero and your reflectance if you plug in
here this is real this imagine this
realistic measuring the modulus is one
right so reflectance is one so the
particle is all reflected it's expected
right it's through a ball on below the
wall the part of your the world they
bought the ball bounced back but there
are still something special
okay you look at the other side of war
the ball the war there is a silent wave
of the war love the ball right that's
because if you look harder they transmit
huh
so also the transmitting there's no real
particle goes through the wall the
barrier right but the wave is now zero
because here this is my wave by t minus
I Omega T Kate who is imagine right here
do is imagine so imagine x imaginary
real is negative real so it's negative
exponential decay function so in this
case what I have is this is the poor
community the puddle comes in and there
is a fan of the wave on the other side
of the interface the type the average
speak and there is no particle go into
the other side but the wave function is
now zero on the other side right and
this wave is called evil axon wave even
nasod okay and
now what's the magnitude of this right
so if you look at your decay of this
even lesson where if you look at the K
of evil action where is really the
magnitude of the e maceió to mh5 square
that's the square root this is really
the magnitude so what I have here the
neck the magnitude of K is 2m really in
maceió
and H bar squared that's why with the K
tool that's of the decay right or you
must see right so if I look at the
electron yo master yi let's say take a
1/4 of an electron volt so the energy so
what's the order magnitude is a 2 times
the line point 1 10 to the minus 31 and
electron volts why Nitron watts is 1.6
10 to the minus 19 and H bar square H by
is a 1 10 to the minus 34 so 68 right so
this Y is 31 19 gives me 50 right and
this gives me 68 so that's 18 18 square
root is of the order of line right and
the rest is okay here it may be I have
five order of line universe meter okay
so that's the magnitude of this wave
extent if it's a electron in to the
other side is of the order inverse of
that gives me what to answer all right
so it's a evil accident rapidly decay
explanation rapidly decay wave on the
other side say who cares - on stones
right then let me tell his story so
there was this guy he just finished his
PhD and went to a job interview at the
IBM Zurich and the name is finish and
they interviewer asked him say they want
to measure the surface roughness now for
RC - very high precision asking him
whether he had the ideas or not and he
thought about this and came up with the
idea that's is using meadow tip and this
is a metal surface right and he put a
bias so vacuum here there's an energy
level that's you rather work function
maybe you didn't read the you read a
little bit later the wave nature the
particle nature of light per se there is
a few electron volts gap here the
barrier vacuum right work function of
the metal so here is a few electron
volts and they say if you bias it with
the voltage right the electron
exponential decay but once they meet
that the other melih become alive again
we'll talk about that
that's a colony of this evil lasting way
and it's a very sensitive to atomic
scale bumpy pumpless right because this
is an strong level exponent sure
so with that you can measure to this the
principle scanning tunneling microscope
you really can measure the electron wave
function on the surface so you can
actually image the atoms and so we got a
robbery price for that
hopefully you'll get a chance when you
have an interview like that you have to
think of be able to come up with the
idea right so that's the the quondam
work it's going up a hill now you
reverse it you say well if you're my
electron is going backwards from here to
here is there a reflection you look at
the revision there's no difference even
you go down here even if you're not go
barrier you go a step down still have
reflashing
right you have discontinuity in putin
sure you have reflection there okay so
this is the in fact this is a lot more
incidence right and when you consider
actually electrical interface resistance
for example electron can actually come
to interface not just a lot more it can
come all directions and you should be
able to sit there and do any angle in
incidence right
in fact I check a lot of electrical
engineering book
nobody even did that it was a surprise
okay if you electric and you know you
should do this okay so this is a full
electron wave and now let's go we say
this is scalar wave it's the easiest and
let's go to more complicated and let's
look at the vector wave
and I'm vector wave the next complicated
vector way is the electromagnetic wave
right young waves it's a big leap from a
Schrodinger equation which is a scalar
equation which is a by no means easy to
solve
you can be got a model where electrons
are you are they're actually not good
tool to solve that right now if you even
if you have two or three electrons their
mutual interaction becomes a very
difficult to solve and that's many-body
problem but say let's go to two young
waves and for that you have to go to
Maxwell equations right and the even you
forgot it but you heard about it
so let's write rewrite the Maxwell
equations and we have four equations you
cross ash mass time derivative you can
see the cross E and cross H is d DT plus
the current and we have then the
divergence of the displacement field
equals a charge density and the magnetic
a diverging magnetic induction is zero
and just to reveal this is a essentially
what the first equation say if you're
changing magnetic field you have we
generally like to the field the
secretary if you pass a current is
through a coil right your general
magnetic field and this is a day Friday
law this is a more like a and personal
right some of the high school experiment
and Maxwell only add the one term you
can get all the credit
okay so what we have here E is the
electric field right the electric field
is the gradient of the electrostatic
potential and so the unit is going to
meter right and H is a magnetic field
and sometimes I don't remember the unit
so I go back to think of this current
density I know right current density is
here is an ampere meter square so here
is the USA times of one meter that gives
me my gratia field is and per meter
right so I'm glad you feel is the ampere
meter and D is the electrical
displacement displacement and what do
what it means is if you have a material
right you have atoms atoms as the
electrons aisles right if you have a
electric field comes in you know that
they will get polarized right positive
charge has a force along the field the
Russian Navy charge opposite further
Russian right so that means they will
have a dipole so you'll have in this
case you have more like a dipole here as
the positive in here is negative okay
right so D is the polarization per unit
volume
dipole moment per unit volume and plus
they if you have original field comes in
converting into the same unit right so
that's a epsilon 0 that's a vacuum plus
the polarization purim the the dipole
moment per unit volume so that for
moment is the dipole moment is the
charge transmitter and per unit volume
is a cubic right so the unit here is a
Coulomb per meter square okay
and from a Coulomb per meter square this
is a Coulomb per meter square you find
the epsilon zero
that's the vacuum permit permittivity I
will see permeability permittivity
permittivity epsilon 0 is 8 point 8 10
to the Mastro and here is a should be
coolant epsilon here is a Farah per
meter okay so I have this one is a far
per meter okay so I have the this is a T
here the displacement field I said that
this is the one external field create a
dipole right you know real solid it's
not that simple because you have atom
here you have another atom here right
how Jason Adams and not only the outside
field but also the legs labor the dipole
itself will affect my sittin the atom
itself so it's actually a summation of
all the C effect okay and this one for
this is an unmovable charge this is the
charge attached to the atom
okay that's died lightly right so you we
sometimes rather epsilon epsilon r and x
ee or this combined together gives me
another if stone that's dielectric
function of the material it's not a
constant sometimes we call dielectric
constant is not a constant
there's a function we've noise it's a
function of frequency okay so that's the
displacement and similarly McClatchy
induction B you can write as a epsilon
vacuum a mill vacuum you are and hence H
right this is just like we write into
the displacement field is it actually
feel time today
dielectric constant and here is the
vacuum permittivity the reality of
tobacco most materials at a high waved
visible wavelengths or high frequency
this one is about one it doesn't have
magnetic response most matures right at
a low frequency you have magnet but say
high frequency most mature them don't
have the magnetic response and in fact
that was the basis of what you mentioned
made by Professor Marin so you say right
he was trying to think about how to you
how do you get a parlous Wireless
cordless power transfer and the problem
is if you want to beam a lot of powers
through this space will all be cooked we
have dielectric response right microwave
you heat it up but I say because
materials at high frequency don't have
magnetic response so it's all about the
using magnetic field to deliver the
power so they start up trying to
commercialize that okay so that's the
basic equations
and our few more comments the relation
between current that's the when there's
a real kind of free electron the current
flow right and car and of course is
related to electric fields from all day
if you have a conductor or semi
conductor that's their own snow so J
equals electric conductivity as Ohm's
know right electric conductivity Sigma
and here the unit is a inverse own semen
meaner right ohm centimeter yeah immerse
know should be inverse or say universal
homie is also semen from inner different
units if you don't use it often it's
very confusing okay so we have all these
quantities and further what is it
if strong say the charge density right
and this charge density is the lac
charge per unit volume in the material
okay so if you have a semi conductor
right you can see my conductor you can
have positive with donor I will not say
if you put a phosphor there okay so
let's say put a phosphorous atom in
silicon and phosphorus lose the electron
so the atom the self is mobile electron
becomes a mobile right so what do you
need is the this is a positive charge
you also have a electron negative charge
you add them all together that's per
unit unit volume how much charge you
have so these are the set of equations
describing
they max the electromagnetic waves and
now we can say why let's do a few math
operation just get familiar with it
right you have seen them so if I look at
this I can eliminate I will first lien
emulator because a B right here I can
write as mu H mu zero times mu R mu and
for me
tivity and so B equals mu H is I use the
first one I get the first equation Delta
cross e equals mass D mu H DT that's the
first equation and the second equation I
have a delta cross H equals D DT and
epsilon times e this is add a dielectric
function which is epsilon zero times
epsilon R write the displacement field
and plus Sigma can see those are they if
I use consider relations and eliminate B
and the D I got the equation here right
and let me first drop this term okay
let's consider a dielectric there's no
free charge in the material so your
actual conductivity is zero okay with
that I can I can plug this H into here
right and I take a time derivative on
both sides on both sides and then I
gather D H so this is assuming mule and
if slow independent of time
right and if it depends on time you have
to be careful it's not mine right oh
okay
so if I if I have the so if I eliminate
if I take this gives a mule out I'll be
independent of time and sometimes you
have to be careful because when you do
those kind of mathematical operation you
make assumptions you may lose the big
opportunities okay and this is
electromagnetic field is there are a lot
of a new concept that is all based on
going back to the original equation and
we look at them and say where are they
say if you say other that where are the
approximations made okay you were
reading your Louis XI chapter as a paper
on photonic crystal right and one of us
a his photonic crystal is really that
the concept in that case the epsilon
which we typically take a uniform right
but see he was really taking this a
unified epsilon as a periodic function
so he put the yips on either Furio
function and that's like a periodic
potential for atoms right if you think
about when we solve with a bang gap of
electrons from Schrodinger equation that
come from the fact that the potential
for electrons is a periodic right
Maxwell equation itself
there's say no potential here right it's
really he put this one epsilon as a
constant and he was really using the
analogy and in fact I say I I spent one
day I was in Berlin we both of us were
wandering in the city so I was talking
to him he said that when he conceived
the concept photonic crystal he he wrote
the paper so photonic crystal what is a
photonic crystal is basically periodic
arrangement awful whatever glass beads
you can think about that right and it's
a if you look at the evolution in
electronic power crystal will have bank
gap and in the 70s there is this concept
of or super lattice quantum Wells now
you read again your sake and - paper and
that's putting multi layers of sin films
right that makes the one to machine you
got the artificial this is whether we
draw the potential P Q article potential
that's the chronicle planning model we
talked before it's but it's artificial
material right so you go from
three-dimensional crystal pure article
potential to 1d and that's a big jump in
concept because they're artificial
column structures right and on the other
hand in optics that you have the form it
tells the letter over a hundred years
people know how to do coding people have
been doing refining optics did call the
multi-layer films right some of this is
a purely an assay anti-reflection or
purely reflecting the purpose and so the
reason is so you have those multi layer
thin film coatings which is typically of
the order like horror wavelengths and
you can code it so that it's of complete
reflecting what does the complete
reflection is the wave function of
electromagnetic wave is zero inside
that's a forbidden it's a band gap in 1d
right so what ya below which proposed
photonic crystal is how to make this
package the 3d
well leisure has is the electron photons
in 3d and see researchers we have
created this one D structure right so
that's the you see the opposite the
Russian going and here is trying to make
photonic analogy of sim fail to 3d ok so
he said that when he wrote the paper you
go to read his paper and there's no math
inside right he was just a concept and
he submitted a paper and you know who he
wants to be reviewer and his friend said
do you really want to pop through this
paper this is really does it look like a
paper doesn't matter just publish it so
that's the word you read ok it's a it's
the fact it's the beginning of a new
field photonic crystal ok so that's a
useful only the function of our periodic
right and then your uncle also be a
function of time in fact I was doing
some when I did my graduate school study
right I never came up with big ideas but
once I was writing down the loads I said
ok because I was doing some stuff during
the opticore say the fossil laser mature
interaction I see
during that process the yips one will
change as a function of temperature and
temperature changes function time so I
have to keep the other there I wrote all
those equations and yours should I say a
few years later my friend asking me I
said actually it's in my nose but it
never got anywhere so one story but
anyway let's continue here I have two
equations I drop this I'm going to name
it that I say mu Epsilon constant and
I'm going to then pull it out and I can
eliminate H and what I have here is the
equation
so if I eliminate age I have a delta
cross Yi over a meal and here I have
epsilon I start to get a wave equation
okay and you can use the vector
operation to write rewrite this into if
you're using a vector relation you will
get a sure there's negative sign in the
front and the hi epsilon square mu
epsilon t e dt square and if I continue
carry that you will be mu sigma de DT
okay this is the one I carry they battle
term the conductivity term if I don't I
have a pure wave equation if I drop this
you can see this is a wave equation
second order in space second order in
time unlike the Schrodinger equation
which is the first order in time but how
the imagine number in the front now I
have a real wave equation is the second
order in both space on time right so
this is the Maxwell equation and if you
look at the typical wave solution plan
wave epsilon is a function for R and T
and this is a vector so that's the
polarization to rush in the electric
field the Russian and this is the
propagation direction Omega T must K dot
R
so this is a plan wave plan with
expression we talked before and you
substitute back into here you will say
is satisfy the wave equation right and
in fact if you do it if you substitute
it back see this left hand side that is
the second order derivative in space so
I'll get a K square so I will get a K
the top K right and the right hand side
I will get a mule Omega square this is
time and epsilon plus I Sigma and Omega
this is the this term combined with the
first term and the rest I Omega T that
this term kinds of the phase factor all
kinds of okay and this way I can write
the expression as because the Omega
square so I have mule ifs long-tailed
Omega square the wave vector is
proportional to Omega for waving in free
space this is a epsilon zero mu zero
free space right and this is a water
they have of electromagnetic wave
because we predict Maxwell equation
predicted the speed of light okay
because when you do this you gather the
magnitude K square equals Omega R
divided by here I do the square root of
epsilon killed mill and this one we can
write it in two
so I can write it
okay the magnitude oh this is a naught
square the magnitude so the magnitude of
K equals Omega times say write say K on
the iCore sake hey that's the dispersion
and say a square root of useful entailed
a meal and typically we define
refractive index as the speed of light
in vacuum divided by speed of light in
the medium right and the speed of light
in vacuum this is if some zero mu zero
and it's approximated it because I say
most of high frequency magnetic response
is one so this is a epsilon
child over epsilon zero and this one is
epsilon R so even for meadows right
very often we tabulate we don't regulate
these two separately we just tabulate
them together into epsilon R the
relative dielectric constant okay so
there are a few interesting story here
again okay you take a positive
derivative going from here to here you
take a square root and you see that's a
lateral solution right and if you go to
look at your Maxwell equation turns out
this way it's a right hand wave so you
go say this leaves lalit the Russian you
like to fill out the Russian right it's
a transverse wave you this is the what
the equation tells you go you check it
wave so electrical field will be
perpendicular to magnetic field will be
perpendicular to K the wave vector the
ration K the wave propagation they write
that's why it's a transverse wave right
it's not the only transference way it's
also right hand with what the right hand
mean is if you recall when you learn
let's say is the e cross H goes to the
wave propagation direction right so this
is the right hand side your Yi the
ration you grab to the H direction the
some point who do they pay the ration
okay so it's a right hand wave it's a
transference way except I say we ignore
the possibility for when you take it
this K square root it could be a
negative also root solution okay
legacy a solution typically are ruled
out but if when epsilon I'm milk could
be licked here right when both of them
could be lick here it turns out you go
back to check the equation I get you
have to take a negative root so this in
fact that was predicted in 1950s by
Russian scientist version ago and it's
paper with a sinful garden okay but the
in 90s people start to pay attention to
it
firstly they are later natural matures
with the front leg here it just doesn't
have lecture mature with mu equal
negative why the natural mature will
have you from Megan here you flown
remember is the response of the material
I think I erased it when you have
electric field of the material polarize
right if it's an electron for example
and when you have external wave comes in
oscillating
the electron creator resisting would say
the Russian feel and if that field is
larger than the incident you get the
league in here is the ration
displacement so the if some become like
him but there's no material with Munich
then say in 90s a 90s people tease the
design is artificial resonate her
structure that create a generator say
artificial magnetic so it you basically
create a loop with the gap and when the
electric current oscillate in this loop
the general magnetic field and we make
the very small the magnetic field it
could be very very fast make it smaller
right and if you bring both ships along
a meal they get here in the same
frequency range you have to go to take
the negative root so become a
left-handed material so ye cross H K
goes the other way so this is a pay go
this way but energy go this way no other
confusion at the beginning because
whether there is this possible or not
and there if you check that new creature
this is a cord metamaterial okay it's
not metal materials M a now the mu e and
what's the interesting story many
interesting stories but some people say
madam at here so we starting metals but
it's not a metal material it's a matte
ha
and they it's really artificially design
the materials who has strange properties
and one of this first achievement is the
design material in microwave range so
that to prove that the refractive index
really should be taking a lengthy value
so that's a really later on your say
it's a pretty strange because when we
think about our
light refraction right this is the
refraction schneller with talk alexis
knodel right but when the aim is a leg
here the refraction actually happened
this way and it's pretty weird so it's
still a very active field and you heard
a Harry Potter story the clocking huh
right the so in that case of what
happens is it could be solution of
Maxwell equation I'm seeing here you
have object this is a sure will be easy
for flu mechanics if you look at fluid
mechanics right and then in small riddle
amber flow go this way right so what it
means the the max flow solution like
this means is you mean you have an
object here if you're away you don't say
far away the the there's no scatter
light right so what do you say you the
light goes run but to say you look at it
it's just like the object doesn't exist
that's what they say some of this string
G fact of who this madam achievers okay
and I think say I'll stop put here but
let's look at now you can see a lot of
really interesting stuff and slow longer
so if you go to check I say this at the
beginning there there are a lot of
people there paper see there's no
Liggett of refraction there see
basically this is a little confusing
because the energy propagate and
information is propagating backwards
typically people like to associate with
vector to information and there's a lot
of debate in literature but now I think
that the debate is all gone and it's a
very active in fact
so I just mentioned that you've son
could be legged here when you've some
negative there is also it turns out that
they again all this is that we're going
to talk more legs lecture
the there is a surface wave we just said
the evil action wave is an exponential
decay on one side right we just say the
electron evil a some way you have photon
evil a stern wave but see this we if
someone's legged here you could have a
surface with that decays on both sides
doesn't exist far away from interface so
there's only confined to the surface and
that's the surface plasmon so when these
are the electron so let's say let me
just do a few photon
no I'll go to this image okay so though
you can say that this is a really
periodic structure in 3d or 2d original
is like films as I said right in fact I
was at the U Syria blog which was you
Syria I remember once I attended a
student this is a meeting there was
another professor just say there's no
prog photonic restore it's just with
prog reflector Bragg reflector is the
day 1d structure people call Bragg
reflector right the 3d gives you a
different name and it suddenly opens to
your imagination and you so people start
looking at a a photonic semiconductor
where you have a gap right and you can
dope your photon photonic crystal and
what does that mean
right and so you can say some of those
is you you can guide the light in the
structures and bending 90 degree and
normally after fiber you can't do that
and you have to make a slow turn if you
use up your fibers but if you use this
kind of structure you can have more
complicated say light path and
metamaterials right and this was the
first experiment where they used a split
ring in fact it's a 2d so they show that
the this kind of structure and it could
have or say negative epsilon and
negative mu at the same frequency range
and it was a pretty large structure and
they did a microbe experimentation night
can indeed go the wrong way
that's not what people see when I bend
the wrong way normally against the
intuition and after that there are a lot
of or
not as structures right and let's look
at the clocking well this is not people
not able to do that yet it's a different
different way of doing it but that's the
sort of what I was explaining right if
you like that doesn't get a scatter into
other directions so essentially if you
have way from way over from if you're
away from entities you don't look at
that there's no reflection signal you
can detect okay and so story is don't
loo don't miss the details okay some of
the tiny effect but it could be a big
story
you